♫ La la la la la la la la la
♫ la la la la la la ♫
(comical detective music)
- [Voiceover] How often do
you have a random thought
and think, "Where did that come from?"
Chances are it's not as
random as you might think.
Your thoughts are influenced
by information that is obtained
from the world around you and filtered
through all of your past memories.
Sometimes thoughts that
may seem completely random
could actually be your mind
unconsciously recalling
information that is closely
linked in your memory.
For example, if your friend
asks you to name a random fruit
while at the same time
they're talking about their
brand new yellow car and their
matching yellow driving cab,
your brain is primed with the word yellow.
So even though there's a
wide variety of fruits,
you're more likely to
jump to the word banana.
(comical detective music)
- Okay, go?
- She held the feather.
- Number one, he ate the banana.
- The dog loves benches.
- She has webbed feet.
- Crumbs are never left.
- The kids were swimming.
- The sun is hot.
Sophia.
An animal?
- [Voiceover] Uh huh.
- Ducks.
- Duck.
- Hippo.
- [Voiceover] Oh, okay.
- What?
- [Voiceover] It didn't work.
- I was gonna say duck,
was my first instinct.
(paper rustling)
- What just happened?
(laughing)
- He ate the banana, yellow.
She held the feather, feathers.
The dog loves benches?
I don't get that one.
She has webbed feet, okay a duck.
Only crumbs are left, feeding the ducks.
The kids were swimming in a pond.
The sun is hot at the pond
where the duck's swimming.
- You know what it was, in my mind
duck was one of the words
that I used and I was like,
"Oh I don't wanna use
a word that's on here."
Whoa.
(bleep)
Mind games.
This is a hippo duck.
What the hell?
Yeah, and science is crazy,
this is also adorable.
(humming)